6 jones to provide
internet services specifically for access
to the school that is subsidized by the
district to all those who
qualify and in the telephone number they
give them all the information they need
to qualify they will receive assistance
to be able to receive this service  from cox
thank you excuse me could you please
introduce me back as the site and it
's helping collaborating with connecting
it nevada there was a technical problem i
would like to make sure people
understand what your
organization is about if
connecting it's nevada organization is an
organization made up of  many
community partners who are really
supporting our students and the
school district so that all
students in clark county and
parents participate in the
access and technology needs survey and
so that everyone can have access to those
who need it can  have access to
a chromebook or computing device and
also  én as well as
internet connectivity to start classes
on August 24
perfect and you were talking to me about three
important functions if there are three
important functions that are being carried out
through this organization with korta
connecting it's nevada and this is one that
families participate  in the survey
you can do it through the internet
either by visiting the website of the
organization or the website of
the cssd dot net district and also by
calling the family support center which
is 1 88 86 16
204 76 and calling this number 1  they
encourage them to participate in the survey
and the people who are
assisting them can take their data so that
they can be counted it
is like a list that we are
verifying of the students to see
who needs connectivity and devices and
that is not the first step  the second
step is that if the family needs
chromebooks to start school on
August 24, the support center takes
that data and sends them  it gives that information to
the schools so that they communicate with
the parents and they can receive the
chromebook or the
computing device and the third step is to see if they
have connectivity if they have internet or
some type of access then
it is known that they already have it and  if
parents cannot be offered
several options one of the options is
internet access through college
communications which made a deal
between themselves 7 and cox communications to give
an inmate subsidized
internet access exclusively for the use of  of
the schools so that our
students can learn
remotely as of August 24,
perfect, Maria, I will give you some data
that we received through the connecting it page,
these are until August 17, they had
this data, correct me if by
chance they
increased  the numbers although it happened
I have that of 311 thousand 229 students
registered in the city it is
approximately 220,000 12
completed the survey
t  I also have the information that
20,726 need Internet access and
181,241 need a computer.
With these numbers, could you give me an
estimate of how many students they have
been able to help up to now? Of course,
if the organization with the Nevada team kids
has  been helping families
since this program began and
we have communicated with the
district through the survey or through
connecting it's nevada whatever right now
connected two 236 thousand 795 students or
families of students so
we have a high number we are
approximately  to 76 percent of the
students who are registered in yes
if they have participated in this survey and
the objective is that they reach one hundred
percent then if they have not participated in
the survey they need or do not need a
device and with connectivity it is important
that  parents
take the survey online or call
the family support center to
participate in the e  nsurvey, as I said,
we only have 76 percent of the
families or students who have
participated,
that all students participate,
perfect, there are many families that not
only have one child, they have two, three,
four,
what happens in these situations, each one is
offered a computer  one in the
internet access could be through
the same house but with respect to the
computers each one must connect
individually obviously with their
respective grade the grade that they are
cutting then in families where they
have several children as how you
offer support help as  How do you solve
this problem, of
course,
the objective is that all families
that urgently need it have
access to the device, so the schools
are distributing devices for each child, they
should, if there are three children at
home who need three devices, please
express that need when  call the
support center or take the survey so
that they can be  an give the devices they
need and as I mentioned
before if currently a
father has a computer and has access to the
internet and maybe one of his children
does not need it but two yes maybe we
give those two children first and then
the third but  eventually we
want every child to have a device and
internet connectivity in the
school district but we are displacing these
devices and cox service for
families who need it first but
every child who needs it
whether there is is there are two or three  or four the
children who are in the home must
receive support and parents can
request devices for each of them
mariah there could be a possibility
that you will run out of resources
we know that we do not have enough
devices for all the students  17
an order has been placed to receive more
devices but according to our
calculations and based on the survey that
parents have received
we have enough inventory to
give every parent that needs it for
every student that needs it a
device and connectivity like i said this
is based on the survey so
take the survey bayer as a
connecting kit send and dot heretic take
the survey or go  to the school district
or call the support center so that we
take into account the need that
you have and so we can
count to see how many devices
we need but according to our
data we have enough for
families who have an
immediate need expressed that it is  they have
reported through the survey
perfect perfect anything else you want to
add I know my word that I am going to
put online where the parents have to go
to dinner the survey that is
crucial and the telephone number to call for the
family support center  but something else
that you want to limit some information
that we are missing, of course it is good for
those parents who still  If
you have not registered your children, it is very
important that you register them in the
schools, so you should call your
school and say that you need support with
the registration of the
students, or you can also do it
through the stage page in that
dot net that is very important because
we have some students who may
not have registered and we need to
count them so that they are ready to
start classes on August 24 and also,
as you mentioned, well, all the
children who need a computing device have
a combo  and connectivity they should
receive but they need to call us at the
center and parents will also receive a
lot of support through
we are going to have an educational line a
line for access so that parents
have support in both Spanish and English
and teachers and everyone in  At
school we are waiting for
the children to return digitally until
this virus disappears, but
we are all going to start classes and the
children are going  Let's learn together
one last question now that
this topic has come up, these resources,
computers and access, that is, at the
moment that we suppose that this video
is cut as quickly as possible, it does not
end as quickly as possible and the children
return to classes  what will happen to
these delivered computers that
you want back
the children will not be able to maintain the
objective is that each student 17
has access to one of these devices
for education not only online
but continuing education then
we are going to  say that we return to class
the students will be able to use their
devices to do homework
assignments and general school work
so they keep the devices and
only return the devices as
has been done before when the
students change grades for example  from
elementary to middle school or from
middle school to high school or when they
leave the school district
ok perfect maria a lot  s thank you for
your time
now by email I am going to send you the data
of our fito faith here you can see the
news I want another question you have
while preparing the story
please let us know here we are
available and thank you for providing
important information to the  community
and greetings over there to everyone
including Miss Xóchitl Sandoval cheers for
me please take care of your skin
well thank you see you later and we don't see meeting
you even if it were through this
virtual medium anyway thank you very much Maria take
care see you later
then